[Music]
david is in montgomery alabama hi david
welcome to the ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen how are you
guys doing today better than we deserve
what's up
fantastic so i'm looking into uh
long-term care insurance for my wife
she's 55 actually we're both 55. so we
probably need to wait another five years
and she usually recommends 60. but
understanding that my question is when
do i consider her self-insured as i
think we're kind of on the cut line for
considering herself shelf self-insurance
or needing long-term care
yeah
um
well self-insured always means you can
take the hit for the expense
without disrupting the whole plan
okay
so let's kind of walk that through the
average nursing home stay in america is
two and a half years
typically
the typical scenario is
uh 75 of the ladies outlive their
husbands
and so the typical scenario is papa goes
into the nursing home
burns through 300 grand and if that was
the entire nest egg he cracks and
scrambles the nest egg
and um scrambled eggs and
dies and leaves mama with nothing
okay so we obviously don't want that so
if your entire net worth is 300 grand
you you can't do that you have to have
uh good long-term care insurance if your
entire net worth is 10 million dollars
you can write a 300 000 check and not
blink so if the average nursing home
stay is two and a half years and the
average cost is around a hundred
thousand dollars a year then that's 250
to 300 000 bucks is your typical
exposure could it be more yeah it could
be but it probably won't be and you
could do in-home care even cheaper than
that and maybe get better quality care
depending on the type of issue that
you're dealing with uh in terms of
caring for the individuals so
uh all that to say if you can take a 300
000 hit and and the person that's left
keep rolling
then you're okay so if you've got a
million bucks
and they're left with 700 are you okay
yeah probably okay that makes sense yeah
probably so what's your net worth
uh 900 yeah well actually probably one
1.1 but yeah 900 yeah and it'll double
if you got it invested well good mutual
funds
oh yeah absolutely and you're 55 so when
you're 62 that's going to be 2 million
okay and and when you are um
70 it's going to be 4 million
yeah so between 60 and 70 between 60
years and 70 years you're gonna have
between two and five million dollars two
and eight million dollars uh you're
self-insured you're fine
as long as you set the investments up
where you can access them and then you
do
okay but be ready to write the check
emotionally
and say that's why i've worked my whole
life so i can take care of my sweetie
yep makes sense oh no she'll be i'll be
long dead before that
should be ready to check herself
same here long dead long dead that's
like he's part of the ramsey estate plan
our entire estate plan is predicated on
me dying first i'm a little worried
a little worried sharon has a plan here
i'm just saying we're the same freaking
age actually she's actually three or
four months older than me you should
probably not say that out loud well
that's okay i mean we've been married 40
years
we'll get through it but oh my gosh
i mean geez hey is there is there oh i
have to die first i don't know it's just
just because i'd be useless without her
that's right hey if looking at life at
um the total net worth package is there
any sort of ratio that we should be
careful of when it comes to how much of
our home is makes up our net worth well
in that case you have to sell you know
with that discussion you have to if you
said okay i have a million dollar net
worth and and 900 000 of it's my home
right uh you can't pay for the nursing
home right without selling the house
so yeah that's a problem
uh or you downsize it and go get a condo
or something whatever and then you can
pay for the nursing home but you got to
sell the house right not saying you have
to live homeless but you got to sell the
house because the key is less about net
worth and more can you eat 300 000 can
you write that check can you write that
check and still be okay there you go and
so if you had a million three net worth
with a million dollar house and you
wrote 300 000 check you ain't okay you
have no margin that's right it's not
okay so you're right that's a good
that's a good clarification that you
don't want it all tied up in that or
let's say you had a whole bunch of real
estate uh and that was your whole net
worth you know what plan on selling a
couple of those houses that's right you
know you're gonna pop one of those
rentals to be able to pay for the thing
and that's just part of it yeah and so
and you know we pray the real estate
market's hot when this happens
so uh lack of liquidity but being able
to access mutual funds out of a
retirement plan that's after 59 and a
half
you're certainly okay if that's where
they are so
not a problem at all